19:15 and italy has just joined the
first world war it sided with the on Tom
powers despite previously having made a
defensive pact with the Central Powers
because it was austria-hungary that
invaded Serbia in 1914 that meant that
it wasn't a defensive war and thus Italy
could sit it out both sides had tried to
convince Italy to join them and it was
the aunt on who won out in the end when
Italy signed the Treaty of London which
promised them all of this territory from
austria-hungary as well as a mountain of
cash or made the 23rd Italy declared war
on the austro-hungarian Empire and Italy
was all in Italy didn't exactly perform
very well during the war but fortunately
their main opponent was austria-hungary
who also didn't perform very well in
late 1917 came Italy's greatest defeat
during the war the Battle of Caporetto
this saw the Central Powers pushed this
far into Italy thus threatening Venice
and also seeing 300,000 Italian
casualties in order to raise morale the
Liberal government promised soldiers
loads of things like the vote and free
land anyway austro-hungarian successes
in the war just like in everything else
didn't last in November 1918 the Battle
of Vittorio Veneto began which saw the
collapse of the austro-hungarian army in
the end of the war in the Italian front
a week after this victory the first
world war was over and Italy was free to
celebrate and gain the lands the Allies
had promised them or at least they'd
hoped during the Paris Peace Conference
the Italians demanded what they had been
promised plus a little bit more the ally
said no and instead gave these Ares to
Italy in the rest of the promised
territories to the new kingdom of
Yugoslavia many Italians felt that this
was a gross betrayal by the rest of the
on tante and this became known as the
Vittorio mutilator
the mutilated victory the displeasure at
the post-war settlement came to a head
when Gabriele D'Annunzio led a group of
armed Italian nationalists of the city
of the umay and occupied it they wanted
Italy to annex it but the government
refused as such it was declared to be a
free state but after the Italian Navy
blockaded the city D'Annunzio
surrendered to make matters worse the
post-war economy was in ruins and since
all of the soldiers had been demobilized
and many of the wartime factories were
closed unemployment skyrocketed
also the promise of land to the soldiers
wasn't honored but they did get the vote
all of this disappointment surrounding
the outcome of the war combined with the
economic downturn meant that people
became much more extreme in their
demands this led to what's known as the
red biennium which saw two years of
increased support for socialist parties
greater industrial action some of which
was quite violent and even calls for a
revolution like that in Russia these
more radical socialists were quite
frightening to
many Italians and to prevent them from
gaining power some turn to a new group
the fascists led by a certain Benito
Mussolini Mussolini had previously
himself been a socialist but he was
kicked out of the party when he
supported Italian entry into World War
one after the war many unemployed
veterans during the Blackshirts a
fascist militia went up and down the
country making life pretty miserable for
any and all socialist they could find
Mussolini wasn't in complete control of
the Blackshirts though regional leaders
like at a low bow bow had immense sway
but did largely accept Mussolini's
leadership the current prime minister of
Italy at this point was a man could
Giovanni G alit II who was a
conservative and disliked the growing
power of the Socialists but also was
concerned about the fascists he decided
to call a new election to Italy's
Parliament the House of Deputies where
he would form a broad coalition which
would include Mussolini and his fascists
the idea was that given Mussolini a
legitimate position in government would
make him act in a more respectable
manner and kill off the fascist movement
the idea was a bad one G le T actually
lost seats during this election and the
Socialists gained them sort of some of
the seats were gained by the newly
formed Communist Party created by a
certain Antonio Gramsci as a result
passing legislation was much more
difficult and the fascists now had
friends in high places in late 1921 the
fascists decided to become a formal
political party the national fascist
party the pmf Mussolini wanted to enter
government via peaceful means but the
party's members wanted him to take power
now on October the 28th 1922 the
fascists conducted their infamous march
on Rome where by tens of thousands of
Blackshirts marched on Rome
Mussolini wasn't there himself though he
was in Milan ready to flee to
Switzerland if it all went wrong Victor
Emmanuel the 3rd was asked to sign an
order allowing the army to open fire and
the black shares the king for reasons
unknown did not and the next day he made
Mussolini the Prime Minister so the
proportional representation system used
in Italian elections meant the no party
ever won a majority Mussolini along with
many others sought to change this than a
man could Giacomo a turbo put forward a
law known as the ature Bo law which
meant that the winning party in any
future elections would get a clear
majority of seats this law was supported
by most parties for two reasons the
first was that everyone hated the
current electoral system since he made
weak government's the second and
arguably main reason they supported the
law was the armed black shirts who were
in the room with them another election
was held in 1924 with Mussolini and the
fascist party standing for the first
time at the head of a right-wing
listen they won about 65% of the vote
and there's a lot of debate as to how
clean the elections were there were
certainly violence against Mussolini's
opponents but he was also very popular
many Italians were hoping he would fix
the country's problems the head of the
Socialist Opposition Giacomo Matteotti
spoke out against Mussolini's victory
saying it was tainted by the violence
inflicted by his followers
shortly after this Matt ERT was
kidnapped and murdered by fascist black
chairs the murder of Maserati forced
many of Mussolini's coalition partners
to abandon him he looked like his grip
on power was slipping the fascist
membership wanted Mussolini to be more
extreme and hostile to his coalition
partners whereas Mussolini didn't want
to lose more support in the Chamber of
Deputies which was becoming more and
more difficult since he was directly
implicated Amati of his murder as such
she took a major risk On January the 3rd
1925 Mussolini walked into the Chamber
of Deputies and dared anyone to remove
him nobody did this is seen as the end
of liberal Italy in the beginnings of
fascist Italy but the difference wasn't
immediate and in many ways there was
little difference at all conservatives
and liberals were still being appointed
to positions of authority that said
Mussolini did become a dictator in late
1925 he went from being the Prime
Minister of Italy to being the head of
the government although he's better
known by his other title in Luce the
leader the next year after a few
assassination attempts he banned all
opposition parties had Gramsci arrested
and enacted strict press censorship the
new regime began a phase propaganda
campaign and sought to present Mussolini
as an unassailable leader in the same
vein as the old Roman emperors
Mussolini's first goal was to fix
Italy's ailing economy he sought to
increase the levels of industrialization
across Italy which were far behind the
other great powers
Mussolini also sought to win several
economic battles to secure Italy's
position as a leading nation the two
most important being the battle for
grain in the battle for the lira the
battle for grain was designed to make
Italy self-sufficient in grain
production the battle for the lira was
meant to make the lira more valuable as
an international currency which would
make importing certain resources of
which Italy lacked more feasible
Mussolini also made an agreement with
pope pius xi to settle the roman
question the pope didn't recognize
italian sovereignty over him and
mussolini cut him a deal we'll give you
some money you'll stop openly
criticizing fascism and the vatican will
gain its independence they agreed and in
1929 the Vatican City became the world's
smallest independent country furthermore
Mussolini's government encouraged people
to take up sports and also urge women to
have more children all of the
aforementioned
mangez largely didn't work a make life
worse for many Italians but it was seen
as their duty to endure for the sake of
Italy their endurance would ideally see
Italy recapture its old glory from the
days of the Roman Empire Mussolini had
promised the Italian people that he
would rebuild the Roman Empire for them
which is why he had ambitions on all of
these countries to the north lay ostry
who everyone knew that Germany under a
certain Adolf Hitler wanted to annex in
1935 Mussolini signed a treaty with
France and Britain known as the stresser
from which guaranteed Austrian
independence you see mo Cellini didn't
really like the Nazi regime in Germany
and the whole German master race thing
made him uncomfortable because he you
know wasn't a German the stresser front
fell apart when Italy invaded Abyssinia
nowadays called Ethiopia which was
conquered by 1937 Mussolini also sent
volunteers to fight in the Spanish Civil
War and in this conflict in the previous
Hitler had given Italy Germany support
and relations between the two countries
improved Mussolini now felt that Britain
and France his time had come and gone
and that Europe would now revolve around
the Rome Berlin axis hence where the
Axis powers get their name Italy in
Germany continued their United Front
over the coming years in 1938 Italy
sided with Germany over the annexation
of Austria and it's later dismemberment
of Czechoslovakia Germany sided with
Italy in 1939 when it sent an ultimatum
to King Zog of Albania to accept Italian
overlordship he refused but there was
nothing that Albania could do and so
annexation in May of 1939 Italy in
Germany signed the pact of steel and
alliance in which both countries
promised to help the other out in the
event of war on September the 1st 1939
Germany invaded Poland and suddenly
world war ii mussolini wouldn't bring
italy into the war until mid 1940 after
the fall of Paris in the October of 1940
Mussolini came up with a brilliant idea
let's invade Greece this was to put it
mildly a complete disaster and Italian
troops were trounced by the Greeks which
forced the Germans to come down and bail
them out and over the next couple of
years things got much worse the tide of
the war turned against the Axis powers
Italy lost its colonies in East Africa
lost many troops aiding with the
invasion of the Soviet Union and after
the Battle of El Alamein lost its Libyan
colony in mid-1943 Sicily then Italy
proper was invaded shortly after this
news September 1943 Mussolini was
deposed and arrested Germany then
occupied the north of Italy and set up a
puppet state the Italian social Republic
which was led by Mussolini because he
managed to escape the rest
of Italy under Victor Emmanuel the third
join the Allies and declared war on
Germany the Italian social Republic was
plagued by issues of partisans Italians
who resisted Mussolini's rule and they
did a great deal of damage to its war
effort by April 1945 the front lines
look like this and on the 25th of that
month the Republic collapsed two days
later Mussolini was captured by
partisans and shot the next day the war
and fascist Italy was over in the
aftermath of fascist Italy not much
changed the same liberals and
conservatives who had been given power
by Mussolini retained it after the war
of course Italy did see a return to
democracy and in 1946 held a referendum
on the monarchies existence Victor
Emmanuel had abdicated on behalf of his
son Umberto ii to make the monarchy more
appealing but the italian people voted
to abolish the monarchy in 1946 and thus
the Republic of Italy was born I hope
you enjoyed this episode and thank you
for watching and a special thanks to
Winston k-word James Bissonnette ozark a
flash Adam Harvey Henry Raeburn Robin
I'm sorry if I mispronounced that Thomas
gastrich and Skye Chappell if you'd like
to learn more about fascist Italy
Mussolini there are some book
recommendations in the description below